moshe morgenstern is on his way to the
main synagogue in the center of mnebrac
home to a largely ultra-orthodox or
haredi
community the synagogue is closed
because of the pandemic
people have to pray outside
morgenstern who works as a lawyer
manages in his three-time
corona task force
there's a stigma in the general public
against the alpha orthodox and against
binney black
people think they had edema all sick and
that they are infecting people that it's
evil
but it's not true i don't think there's
any other community that keeps the rules
as strictly as we do
over 2 400 residents are currently
infected with corvid 19
and there are new cases every day rene
bragg is one of the most
densely populated cities in israel
we have apartments where 20 family
members share
75 square meters and one bathroom one
shower if one person gets sick
everyone will get sick
many don't have internet no smartphones
they can't get information online
but there's information on billboards
the municipality has now set up a
so-called war room to handle the crisis
this is where morgenstern and his team
supported by the israeli army work every
day of the week
except shabbat while some ultra-orthodox
communities forbid the use of modern
technologies
morgenstern's team rely on them every
neighborhood
is monitored to help isolate people who
have tested positive for the virus
we check those people who are newly
infected and send them out of the city
if they agree to it of course because we
believe that the more cases we move
out the less corona will spread in this
city
a family of eight needs to be placed in
quarantine
in jerusalem they are taken by ambulance
to one of the hotels
that have been turned into quarantine
centers
run by the israeli military
morgan stern is back on the road the
virus keeps him busy
all the time it's hard it's very
difficult and very demanding
but i don't give up someone is watching
over us
benebrach is taking up the task to keep
the virus from spreading further
just like the rest of the country which
is in the midst of a second wave
of the pandemic let's take a look now at
the latest developments in the
coronavirus pandemic
mexico has overtaken britain to have the
world's third highest death toll
behind brazil and the u.s mexican
officials have recorded almost 47
000 fatalities british prime minister
boris johnson says he's
putting the brakes on easing lockdown
measures and will instead be imposing
new restrictions
that's after a new spike in coronavirus
infections in the uk
and germany has added three northern
spanish regions to its list of high-risk
destinations
anyone arriving from those spanish
regions will have to produce
a negative virus test or go into
quarantine for two weeks